how do you go between the left part of
your brain the linear part rational part
to the right side creative how are you
able to turn that on and off or do you
never do that you sort of incorporate
the two of them I know you were talking
earlier that he has a great way about
has an empire metal spring yeah he
really does I've never met somebody who
is both so creative and filled with
heart and can is capable of beautiful
words and appreciation of art but who
also has such a keen business sense and
understands a contract like no one my
first when I did a Disney pilot what I
was created this idea was kind of
getting swallowed up in negotiations
John was the one who you know kind of
set me straight anyway he that he really
does he has an ambidextrous ambidextrous
brain so how do you well I think you
know I think indie film has taught me a
lot making this movie taught me a lot
because I did a lot of planning with my
DP and I did a lot of a lot of a lot of
pre-production that in the heat of
production on an indie movie went out
the window and I really had to a lot of
it was flying by the seat of the pants
and I just developed a sense of when
something felt right I didn't have to
know with my left brain why it was right
or if why it was wrong I just gained my
own intuitive sense of when something
felt right and trusted that and later on
I could try to figure out why it was
wrong or how or how to get it right but
I ended up having to trust my instincts
which was a great gift that this movie
gave me I think if I'd had a bigger
budgeted movie and more days and more
time I would have gone back more into my
head and not been so instinctual in the
in in the making of it and I think it
also comes from because you are in an
indie film even though you're the
director and you adapted the screenplay
you're still one of the producers and
they're things that you've got to deal
with on all this so when you have so
much to deal with you just have to learn
to adapt I think we're in a whole
another part of evolution of filmmakers
now it's not enough for us just to be
talented and artists we also have to be
marketers and and business people you
just you need to yeah Kevin Smith is
kind of leading the way on that with
what he's doing with red state it's a
great example and I think you know he
has a huge fan base at burns to is doing
amazing things with that making movies
that don't go up the Africa Lee that
just goes straight to internet into
streaming VOD and I think that's you
know that's both both hopeful and scary
that filmmakers are going to have to
develop themselves as brands in order to
survive I'm not sure how I feel about
that that's a bit of a mixed bag the
artist entrepreneur well John Simon
candy bar well I think you assemble a
team around you you assemble a team of
like-minded creative talented people and
you you help one another there's a just
for the time I've been on Twitter I'm
amazed at how many people who are don't
have the fan base of a Kevin Smith or
Ned burns but they're doing it
themselves with some success I know
Sheree candler is somebody who helps
them and has brought up some examples of
people and yeah it's it's exciting stuff
right now but the days of being just an
artist are gone unless you have your
entourage then who will do tweet and
promote and market for you and I think
what people also have to remember
I think younger filmmakers know this
already intuitively is that the old ways
are gone it's broken that whatever is
going to come next is going to we don't
know it's a it's terra incognita it's an
unknown world in terms of how movies are
going to get out there and be consumed
by people sometimes I think
pessimistically all we're going to be
left with is three minute videos of cats
playing the piano on YouTube and 200
million dollar movies like Avatar and
there will be nothing else because
nothing else will make sense
economically but I know that isn't going
to be the case it's just how we get to
the place where something between those
two becomes a business again you know as
opposed to just a shot in the dark it
was very nice when we had DVDs in home
video and cable and all of these
discrete windows of exploitation you
could make movies and very easily
predict how much they were going to make
today it's just it's just really unknown
even with names in your movie I guess
that's what people still cling to his
name actors as a measure of the worth of
a movie but those days are going quickly
too and it's going to be exciting to see
what happens with I think radio free
album booth is going to be be maybe one
of those cutting-edge movies that we may
end up trying to push the boundaries of
how it's marketed and who we work with
and things like sponsorship there was a
movie that our composure robyn hitchcock
i think was involved with that had a
premiere on youtube sponsored by Toyota
for a hefty sum that pretty much paid
for the paid for the movie I mean that
kind of model and now we'll go up
theatrically of course theaters don't
want to play movies that have been on
the internet first it's all a negotiate
it's all a huge negotiation and a big
wilderness that we're facing as we go
into this kind of digital digital future
of everything all at once whenever you
want it this has been big on our plate
and what we've been talking about and
more options have come up since they
we're really very nice variety review
this week but when we come to a
conclusion on what exactly we're going
to do for radio free album with maybe
we'll come back and talk to you about
that because we're we're throwing up you
know ring options if you'll have us if
you'll have this for